several groups are now fighting to stop
the federal government from capturing
wild horses and new video obtained only
by the 8 news now i-team is one of the
reasons why the i-team's vanessa murphy
here in studio with this story you are
seeing right here first
wild horse advocates argue this needs to
stop for several reasons but perhaps the
most important reason they say it's
inhumane we've obtained video showing
what happened to one horse and i want to
warn you
it's
graphic the harm that it causes
this callousness
is beyond description a young horse with
a broken leg tries to run from a
helicopter this is part of an operation
by the federal government to capture
wild horses advocates say the animal
should have been euthanized immediately
but that's not what happened the roundup
should cease the priority should not be
getting that band into the trap laura
lee has reno based advocacy group wild
horse education which provided this
video to the i-team everything should
stop and that horse should be put down
immediately
not
wrote
not put on a trailer and made to be
driven down a bumpy road while it tries
to stand on three legs as a baby for who
knows how long before they finally put
it out of its suffering lee's group
along with two other non-profits filed
this lawsuit in federal court against
the bureau of land management or blm to
stop this operation this land is known
as the pancake complex nearly 1.2
million acres 30 miles west of ely the
blm insists there's only space for just
more than 600 horses while estimating
the current population at more than 3
200.
advocates say birth control through
darts is a better alternative to help
control the population lee points to
consistent failures by the blm to plan
so we have plans for minds plans for
livestock plants to protect sage grouse
but we don't have management plants for
wild horses she says this roundup should
have never happened here at this time of
year one reason the temperature which
makes the ground slippery as the horses
try to get away
according to this lawsuit this cult
suffered with that broken leg for 29
minutes until he was finally euthanized
lee also points to this video of other
captured horses and so what they were
doing in loading is slamming the gate
on the horse at the back of the trailer
to get that horse to load slamming the
horse's back legs trying to get him to
lift his legs she says she believes
these actions violate a policy for
humane treatment of the animals she
previously fought for she tells the
i-team this video shows a lack of
enforcement it's really rough when the
person doing the abuse is also in charge
of policing that abuse
according to the blm's website 11 horses
were euthanized so far during this
current roundup more than 900 have been
captured since it started last tuesday
lee says her team is on the ground there
to continue to try to document what's
happening but they're being kept a mile
and a half away the i-team first aired a
story about this on january 14th denise
and it received quite a response you
know thanks for that warning because
watching that that video is is really
tough to watch but that's what happens
out there so we need to let our viewers
know so so what's next in their fight so
a hearing is expected to take place this
week in front of a judge and we'll see
if the judge decides to stop the roundup
completely or maybe create guidelines
and we'll follow that and let our
viewers know all right so i know that
you've reached out to the blm on
multiple occasions um any update with
hearing from them uh yeah we reached out
again this time and they declined to
comment for this report a spokeswoman
referred us to their website which has
information about that roundup we'll put
that at eightnewsnow.com this really is
a complex issue the i team especially
george knapp has been covering for years
we have those stories at
eightnewsnow.com all right good job on
that update thanks for for that